okay we've got one final speaker um
with us today this is beth rosenberg
with tech kids unlimited at the ability
project with nyu
and beth is going to be speaking to us
about
teaching and learning for neurodiverse
students
um beth you have the microphone
hi everyone thank you so much for having
me
my name is beth rosenberg i'm an
educator
i teach at nyu tandon as an adjunct
professor
and i am the founder and director of
tech kids unlimited and i'll tell you
that story and i'm gonna tell you about
our research
um that we've been working on for the
past three years
i also before i start i just want to
thank um
um richard ladner who's been a real
champion
of tku and also thanks to the work of my
israel who's very influential to me and
two people
are here actually that i want to shout
out to claire
kearney volpe and meg gray who
i've had the privilege of working with
at tku as amazing educators
and one of my own staff members my
education manager jessie
harrell is here who's pretty amazing as
well
so um i love cats
i'll just let you know that okay but
before that
um after that um so
um i i really want to thank also my
collaborators on this presentation you
can see
who they are um there's no i in team
and um the team is made up of um our
very small staff at tickets unlimited um
cuny college of staten island
and nyu tandon school of engineering and
you can hear all the people there so
um what is neurodiversity of judy singer
and australian sociologist who coined
the term in her own dissertation in 1999
um who is on the spectrum
basically said that um we need to accept
disabilities as valuable aspects of
human diversity
by reframing deaf deficits as
differences examining how society
contributes to disability
and viewing all people as neurologically
unique and deserving of the same rights
so we've seen this definition before um
in the past two days um and but i
you know as you're reading a little bit
more about this definition i just want
to let you know that the employment
outcomes of people with
autism spectrum often fail to reflect
their potential
and in 2012 there was a national survey
done
by paul shattuck who's an expert in
employment that 44.9
of youth with asd um
often fail to off never obtain
any form of paid employment um in their
six years after
high school we've also found that social
skills and soft skills such as teamwork
and collaboration skills
are highly valued by employers but
they're never really targeted by job
training programs in specific skill
areas
um one of our students in 2018
we did a a pre-test
um when we were serving some of our
students and
yikes my um you could see all my
emails coming in um apologies for that
um that you know really coming back to
self-understanding and thinking about
improving um students identities as a
pathway to
better learning outcomes this is a quote
from a student with autism
who was asked how he would define autism
before he attended a workshop and as you
can see
he has a pretty negative view
of this label you know autism is bad and
i don't think anyone should have it it
stops people from doing the normal
things
i don't have autism um and so
you know this was a pre-test um
surveying this um student and then at po
post tests after he had a one week of
working
you know at tech kids unlimited um he
um uh so it went from
62 of students um describe
challenges associated with autism and
then 37
describe challenges associated with
autism
after one week of working with tku so
let me just tell you that
um this story of tech kids unlimited is
a personal story
um to me the person was political on my
second child in 1998 by the time he was
two years old he was not only diagnosed
on the spectrum but he was also
receiving
intervention in the form of speech
therapy occupational therapy
a see it play therapist a team of
applied behavioral analysis
therapist who um worked
with him for 20 hours a week over the
course of four years
and you could see you know what he
looked like before his interest in
technology he's now what he looks like
now in the striped search
uh striped shirt and my team at um tku
which he um has taken classes at tku now
for 10 years
um so my kid was beginning to love
technology
um he wanted to be on a computer um so
what did i do um i began my career as an
educator working with underserved
students at the guggenheim museum
so i just basically did what like us
devoted moms
do is i created a program for him and
now in
220 in 2020 we now serve 450 students
like him
um so why unlimited people often say
that to me
and it's because students with autism
spectrum's outcomes can be unlimited
if they're taught in specific ways and
that's where
the skills the social emotional and the
self-advocacy and understanding
really come together so the mission and
guidelines and admission
challenges is that sometimes our
students know why they're having trouble
and sometimes they don't
we're using methods we've heard about
all week long um it's not like
neuroscience we're using individualized
supports scaffolding breaks one-to-one
supports all of our programs are virtual
now but are held
at the ability project at nyu tanzan in
brooklyn which is our
beautiful partner and because we run an
out-of-school
education program we often have limited
info
about who's in the room when compared to
a student in school
so you know neurodiverse students they
get lost in the shuffle
they're misinterpreted as disinterested
as defiant
as lazy um as ultimately missing out on
the learning experience
um we started with a one week program
in night 2009 and we just kept
growing because the need was there and
we became a non-for-profit
in 2014. in 2020 we now have 10
different kinds of programs for youth
teens
young adults and families and we operate
all year long
and our job is to help students with
disabilities learn to recognize what
they need
learn to express what they need and you
know help them develop strategies to
help themselves
um what do we teach you can see um we're
project-based we're about experiential
experiential learning and
you know an important piece for us is
the um
social-emotional um castle framework
um this is the collaborative for
academic social and emotional
learning which began their work over 20
years ago um
i think it's really interesting that we
have really only as
educators started focusing on this in
the past three to five years
um in all of our workshops we have a
social worker who
steps in to deal with things like
anxiety and frustration because
learning um computer science thinking
can be really frustrating
um i like to tell my son um when he's
really frustrated
you know around about like the idea that
his brain is a rubber band
and if he doesn't constantly stretch it
um in terms of the growth mindset that
it's just gonna
snap and disintegrate so
um some of the pedagogy that we use
includes you know universal design for
learning
um and i know many other programs use
this as well
um you can see um in our slides like
you know not only you can see that we
are
um you know doing specific
things around engagement like giving
students choices
in project content um and you know there
are some students that come to our
program and the parents say look
um my kid probably won't be able to do
anything
or doesn't want to do anything and he
just wants to be around other students
so just you know have him interact with
other students you know have him work on
a computer as best he can
but i don't really care what the you
know end project
um will be um so in this particular
slide um we're you know interested
um you know in you know how do our
students
you know engage um and you know the
relevance
you know the why the relevance to the
learner's
interests their identities their needs
and so on
um the what which is how information is
delivered
um and here's the um
the what um using different presentation
styles
visual auditory hands-on
you know we like to use lectures demos
follow along cheat sheets we use the
accessibility features
speech to text is super important to our
students
many of them are dyslexic and dysgraphic
as well
um we just use every tool in our arsenal
um
to you know get these students to
um succeed um
you know in terms of participation we
um if students don't want to talk um
that's okay
they don't have to um you know
they don't have to get up in front of
the class and and talk about their
project
only if they want to you know we do a
little pushing with our social worker
when we see that a student is able to
but they may have you know a little bit
of stage fright
um and we we really
try to um you know think about having
our students
um work on analog tools like paper
and you know coloring even and then push
them
you know onto the harder work um in our
program
so these are just some of our projects
that um our youth have
um created and the youth program
is um goes from age seven to thirteen
and we're all virtual now
and you can see that you know students
will use you know they'll make comic
strips they do editing
they do video editing photo editing
sounds editing
um they loves me they love memes and
gifs and then
the teen projects are more work-based
oriented
in that um they
are working on websites and
logos and videos for clients
and we actually charge clients
a little bit of money um it's considered
a donation
and you can become a client
of the tku digital agency and you can
see our new website
um screenshot up on the upper left hand
uh corner um so you just go to that um
website which is just um tkuagency.com
and if you have a project that you need
done our
teen students will um do it for you and
we wrap a curriculum
you know around the project and uh
the students feel really really good
that they
are um you know making something real
um we also did a project with the
flutie foundation doug flutie foundation
we have a
website um called shop the spectrum
which the students created and they're
you know updating it and they're also in
charge of the social media
um and if you know holiday time is
coming up and if you want to support
you know the cause just go to shop the
spectrum it's like an etsy
for um autism entrepreneurship
okay so now that i've told you all that
about this about the program
what i really wanted to talk to you
about was our research
um today and our
research um started really in 2017
and we in 2017
um our evaluator ariana riccio
she really wanted to look at the
technology skills the social skills the
job skills and the self-understanding
of teens in our program and so she sort
of like slapped a lot of spaghetti
against the wall
to see like what was working like were
the students
really learning you know um
computational thinking and technology
skills
um were they improving their
self-identity
um along the way so that's what we did
in 17
in 18 we went and developed a structured
curriculum an assessment plan
and in 19 um we evaluated the impact
of the curriculum so
what i think is sort of really
interesting is that
um in 2017
um we surveyed um parents and students
um and we spoke to 15 students around
age 16 and their parents
um we spoke to each individual before
and after they attended a tku workshop
for one week over the summers
and while you can see the research um
the data is that
students wanted to learn tech skills at
tku while parents
wanted their team to learn social skills
and so what we learned from this was
that um
students and parents are not always
aligned when reflecting on their
um their own teens career and learning
goals and outcomes
um in addition we looked at their soft
skills and we asked the students what
skills do you need to do teamwork and at
pre-tests you know they listed all these
different things you know cooperation
listening communication
patience planning leadership um you know
and then at post-tests after one week
they saw that um wow you know wait a
second
you need to use communication a lot more
43.8 and also they added two soft skills
which was collaboration
and compromise um they had no idea about
that
so then we also asked them about job
preparation in 2017
um and you can see it pre-test um what
happened and then
you know um at post-tests i love this um
this data set here because you know all
these kids come in and they're like i
want to be a game designer
you know i want to do this i want to do
that you know in technology and then
um you know once they realize that like
working in technology
means sitting in front of a screen a lot
of the time
you know they're like wait a second i
don't want to do that i may not this i
may not want to do that i may not want
to be a game designer
um but also um they really didn't
understand
um about jobs at all like you know this
whole idea of
of you know will stem lead to jobs
it was it's like a complete unknown so
our findings suggested after exposure to
technology-based programming students
adjust their aspirations highlighting
the value of experiential learning
for helping students move toward careers
well aligned with their interests
students express interest in stem jobs
but they're unaware of job preparation
strategies to obtain
these jobs um we ask students how they
would find a job when it's time to look
for jobs and most couldn't tell us
how they would do this at pre-test but
only 25 percent of students struggled
with this question post-test we think
this highlighted a strength
of our tko tku programming where we
often talk about goal setting and
planning
this approach to systemic thinking may
have translated well when we asked
students to think about the problem of
finding a job
so after 2017 we thought okay we've got
to redo everything
and so in 2018 we um
came up with a new curriculum template
by my amazing
um education manager jesse herrell who's
on this call too
thank you jesse and we did a couple
different things we thought well
maybe we if we did a two-week workshop
blend that would be good
and um we're gonna infuse our regular
curriculum template which has a ton of
things in it like
breaks and and um um
presentation things and and you know
room for sensory um seeking
um time and what if we really
infused our regular template curriculum
template with a real focus
on universal design what would happen
so we redid a lot of things and focused
on how our teachers are teaching the
material
for us it's critical not only to
implement universal design for learning
in the classroom
um in out of school times programs but
to evaluate how that program is working
in context and impacting student
learning goals
the tku curriculum template functions to
guide the teachers and
also became a helpful evaluation tool
in 2018 we asked students how did tku
teachers help you understand what they
were teaching
and um basically you know what did the
students like in 2018
in terms of you know how they were
learning
um and we looked at the strategies the
teachers used at posttest
we wanted to capture
how students responded to the udl
instructional practices this question
because this question here how
um deals mostly with content deliver
delivery or the purple what of the brain
these student
responses provide a good example that
each learner connected with a different
delivery content and engagement style
we asked um the students how did your
teacher make the material interesting to
you
and um this question deals mostly with
what made students feel connected to the
content or the green
why of the brain the first two responses
highlight that the instructor's focus on
student enjoyment and relevance of
content
because many of our students love video
games help students feel invested in the
material
and then we continued on that path um
i liked when my teacher used and you can
see
that um student preferences um
you know came from this post-test in
you can see the variety of preferences
indicated
the one thing that the students didn't
like was just public speaking
they would rather learn um through
you know videos games direct examples
so
in this slide we asked the students um
what um please check all the things that
you know
you like the teachers um use
um for and we highlight here self-paced
activities
and activity choices indicating that
providing opportunities for students to
choose their mode of participation is a
valid way to increase buy-in
and then to parents we ask them what
skills do you think your team learns
and um they basically
said that um you know it switched a
little bit
um we were able to push up
the social skills you know by about 25
um you know while we incorporate a
social emotional learning checklist in
the template
applying udl practices should inherently
increase
sel skills by varying engagement and
action styles social skills are clearly
desirable by parents and employers
of course soft skills dominate every top
10 job skill
list for today's market
and then we moved ahead
and looked at um 2019
and um we went from
so we had the udl curriculum and then we
were more deliberate about connected
learning and group work
and with an emphasis on work readiness
and soft skills
you know teens kind of don't care about
social skills they want to learn
computer skills but the parents
want them to learn social skills
and then finally you know we were lucky
enough um
you know we're very excited to have been
awarded a national science
foundation grant in august 2020 for the
next three years
um and um like um
miss august was saying yesterday with
the intentional profiles with eye gazing
game software we're also really
interested in intentional profiles but
we're doing it a little bit different
so part of our 2019 survey with students
looked at their attentional profiles we
gave them surveys around
measurements of executive functioning to
see if they were good
at switching tasks to task or are they
a more focused attentional profile where
they focus on one thing
very intently we wanted to assess how
engaged they felt during a lesson and to
do this we gave them
surveys four times a week we really did
but we paid them for it
we paid them five dollars a week for
doing these surveys
and each of the surveys were about two
minutes per survey it was pretty funny
like
the people would like run up to that
kids would run up to us and say like i
did the four
surveys this week where's my five
dollars um
so the plan for the nsf is to identify
the evidence to tell us which teaching
methods are best
suited for students with focused
attentional profiles and which
methods are best for students who often
switch their attention
we're also looking at stem self-efficacy
at tku
does the tku program improve
computational thinking
because you know self-efficacy is a
person's belief in his or her own
ability his or her own ability to
succeed
in a particular situation and we want
our students to succeed
so stay tuned
thank you beth um so much information
there what a great talk
um i love how you just sort of slid in
there that sometimes
parents and kids aren't aligned on their
career plans
um as the father of two 17 year olds
that sounded like quite an
understatement to me
um i we have a question from the
audience um
uh from richard ladner who you mentioned
in your talk
um he says hi ben uh you mentioned
applied behavioral analysis
can you describe what that is and what
you think of it
great question thank you so aba is an
evidence-based strategy um
that once you have the autism diagnosis
um is you know the strategy that is
recommended for students to
um for young students and even older
students now um all the students are
using it
um to help those um students so
um it's based on the bf skinner
um and his research with birds
um you know give a bird you know
up you know tell the birds to do
something and you get a reward
and so um you know some people have a
very um negative view of aba
i have a very positive view and i
probably have a positive view because
when aba
is done correctly it really is
um like amazing i mean my son
i shudder to think what he would have um
what he would look like
without um having the aba
you know he was taught everything in aba
from
colors to numbers um and in the very
beginning
when he was two years old it you know
veggie booty was
the um you know was the the
the reward it was like okay say the you
know the first 10 numbers you know in
this book
you know or count from a to you know a
to z
uh say the letters of the alphabet
here's your piece of veggie booty
maybe it doesn't work on all kids um it
works on my kid
and what's interesting is i see that um
in
in in our classes
you can kind of tell the kids who have
had aba
the kids who can sit who can be
attentive
um those are kids who have definitely
had
some kind of aba um and the kids who are
sort of all over the place
um they are um
you know harder for them to focus
um and i it's it's a little bit of you
know
you know turn your child into an
automaton
in a way but you know the important
piece you know once you have the
straight aba
is to then generalize and how do you
take the learning that happens
in their room their little room you know
or their you know little corner
with the aba therapist which is done in
two hour increments at a time
um and how do you generalize it into the
outdoor world
when my son started with aba there was
no such thing
as um it was called a bcba
a baccalaureate um and so
i got just very lucky now in order
to provide aba to students you have to
have
a bcba which is a very hard degree to
get
and teachers usually get it psychology
students get it etc and i'll tell you
something
you get a lot of money once you pass
that bcba test
well i can understand how that can be
motivating for some young people
okay uh thank you very very much beth
appreciate it
um also i'm gonna post in the chat ruth
farmer uh
shared that your blog went live on the
cs for all uh
website today so i'm sharing that with
all of our participants too
thank you thank you so much for having
me sure thank you
um okay with just two minutes left in
our speaking
uh time here i'm going to share some
wrap-up thoughts with everyone
let me see if i can get this uh out for
everyone to see
um and then we'll head right into our
break
uh i will assume that um this is working
for everyone but if not i'll i'll read
what it says
um so the the white papers which is
where we're gonna head to
after our short little break uh on the
break uh with the breakout groups
um are meant to be a tangible outcome of
this workshop but
by no means are they meant to be the end
of what we do together
um they're meant to be sort of a
springboard for something that
can come next and that can be some
collaborative research
that happens with people from your group
um
you might have made some connections
here with some of our speakers with some
of the other people in your breakout
group
that hopefully you'll you'll want to
carry forward i know i have with my
breakout group and
i've seen some uh people get to know
each other in our breakout group that
hopefully will
turn into you know some good networking
uh professional
collaborations down the road um we do
have a timeline for these
uh white papers um i'm gonna ask the
all the breakout groups to spend some
time at the end of your time together
today
thinking about how you can get a good
draft
written by december 15th and so you'll
have to figure out what
what processes you have to put in place
for that do you want to meet again
virtually
do you think you can do it all um via
email or
some other way that you can get that
done
december 23rd will be a due date for
comments so on the 15th when we receive
all your drafts
we're going to share those internally
with this whole working group here
so that we can read each other's white
papers and offer comments to those
groups
you might see that there's an
intersection with something that you're
working on
or just have a suggestion or an idea
that you want to comment on that paper
you won't be able to make edits directly
into that paper
but your comments will then be reviewed
and incorporated by the authors of that
paper and they'll have a week
to think about what they want to do with
all of that uh and then
after that week we'll um publish the
papers
um and we're gonna aim for january 12th
for that uh
and we're gonna announce them to the
world
and uh use all of microsoft researchers
uh social media
uh muscle to to make those as widely
shared as possible another
possible next step with all of this is
an upcoming call for proposals with our
ai for accessibility team
you'll receive this link when we send
out the wrap-up email later today and
you can
find more information about that um
something else
um that i hope that we can do with this
community that we've
galvanized here and hopefully we're
catalyzing some new
um collaborations together is think
about whether or not we want to have a
follow-up workshop
and it'd be great if someone in the
audience here decided that they wanted
to host the next one and
um invite the program committee to help
them assemble it i think
some of us might be interested in
helping to support that as well
and think about how we want to carry all
of these these great
you know progress that we've
accomplished together forward
and keep the momentum going um so keep
an eye out for the feedback survey
that'll
be really important for us to know what
worked for you what didn't work for you
how can we keep improving
our model uh for delivering these kinds
of events
um and uh and and so we hope that you'll
take a few minutes to
respond to that uh when you get it uh
later today or tomorrow
um okay so that's it um now we're two
minutes over time
please take your break that you need to
stretch your legs and and do whatever
you have to do for the next
uh 15 minutes or so uh and do plan to
come back to your breakout groups
um and uh we'll see everyone together
again at 12 15
for the final wrap-up of the breakout
groups today
okay thanks everybody